welcome to this video which covers the
game kayaking against aronia from the
seventh round of the candidates
tournament and yeah before this round
aronia on +1 just on plus one after he
had spoiled this amazingly winning
position against our Drake in the last
round and kayaking yeah he's on minus
one he's so suffering from this loss
against Kramnik and besides that he only
made a couple of draw so he really needs
to to move at some point and get a win
if he wants still have a chance let's
see what happened in this game today man
yeah we got the e form and not much of a
surprise Aronian is exclusively
exclusively playing e5 and here
yeah it's again the balloon yeah yeah
this is played so often but okay I can
promise you that this won't be a dog
game I really can so bear with me it
gets interesting it only takes about d3
in plate not the end game and TM Bishop
c5 c3 castles
yeah he has an interesting moment he
just canceled but when I when I had
looked at this was black brain I have
played the Bullen once in a while myself
and I was always a bit concerned what
happens if they just take all my pawns
it turns out that d5 in this position is
very good for black but it's important
to know that white cannot grab even more
this will lead to big trouble already
note that something like I know where to
go even here black will take yeah that's
also Bishop a6 in the mix in the mix so
not advisable to to grab really yeah
castles is better yeah until black now
plays d6 we
have from position that has been played
in this tournament already for instance
between under Aiken and kayaking as
black but huronian is played differently
he plays a rookie age which i think is
interesting it at the moment does not
play the D pawn and allows after 92 to
play a six yeah and this is a really
interesting now if if white now does not
take on c6 this is what kayaking played
instead to this for example like it can
play b5 let's say let's say here and
then shower
can you play d5 even yeah well I can at
least play d6 and then we have a pretty
regular looking position from the let's
say yeah normal Rui with a six earlier
but white is already committed to d3
this is certainly nothing that black
should fear he took on c6 you know this
is maybe the more more testing testing
move d takes and night C form yeah
that's interesting he takes e5 and black
no needs to make some sort of small
concession to keep the pawn protected I
did enjoy you're not sure you want to
play this him you must reckon with g4
and giving up the bishops already yeah
you also don't want to do that so to cut
them you probably need to play 97 which
is not terrible it at the moment blocks
the the bishop that's a bit bit awkward
but you will very often get back into
play like that or to g6 so not a big
problem before Bishop twist to d6 and
Bishop to b3
the Queen to b3 the position is
relatively close so black is not in a
much of a hurry he can improve pieces
Bishop g5 now plate yeah of course you
must avoid that check so it's it's a
peace move and okay there's only Queen
d7 available yeah a bit awkward but it's
not really a problem black is still
sufficiently coordinated Bishop e3 and
Knight to g6 yeah this is activated
looking at importance squares and what
black is trying to do is to get some
harmony back in this pieces like Queen
here and Bishop to e6
yeah and kayaking is playing 92 bishop
f8 back securing this bishop so that
it's not traded now bent for D form so
we have an crisis in the center he wants
to do something and well it is it's
tough to suggest anything else really
besides deform you have a hard time to
prepare something like f4 and d4 is the
only pawn break so he is going for that
queeny's happen yeah this is no this is
the idea of course black finally wants
to develop his Bishop from C aid and of
course he also needed to lend some cover
to e5 yeah here in this position
kayaking took on e5 this is a move that
he actually criticized later in the
press conference he gave this line takes
takes takes takes as better and now he
said that F form community 6 + f5 would
lead to an endgame that is about equal
and tough to lose for white yeah that's
probably true but
this is not forced I'm not quite sure he
said that Queen e6 looks like the most
natural to him I personally would have
thought that Queenie 7s natural here to
prepare Bishop e6 the computer however
gives Queen B 5 and just gives black an
advantage a move that he didn't mention
the idea is that this is simply a weak
spot and it's not clear what white is
doing him they move like a 4 for example
it's already very tricky for white now
I'm not sure that this really is a big
improvement on the other hand I believe
that what he played in the game while
not really promising much is also not a
problem at all he took with the pawn and
then go up the should be six introduce
this threat so widely de to retreat with
the Queen and now we had this
simplification yeah and this is what
yeah okay I can thought that this is
very comfortable for black that's
certainly true black does not have any
problems but he's also not so not better
and therefore there's not much to to
criticize I believe I I don't really
think that y can in any way think of
playing for an edge anyway the here how
does white play for an advantage
you've given black the pair of bishops
and he does not have any particular
weakness so it's it's probably just a
logical outcome that it is about equal
yeah he now retreated to d2 if he takes
on e5 which is somewhat more natural you
have this problem black is quickly
attacking here and his pawn majority no
okay there is a double porn but you can
now get rid of it
black it's just a bit more active here
it's nothing special though I mean
Coyoacan could have played that it's not
like he's losing instantly this is a bit
more young it's a complicated
but also already fine for black gap good
move
looking at those crucial squares and
yeah every makes sense Nagi for you
really don't want to happen the mix as
well and now he played Knight to c4
yeah blacks plan is to invent on the
light squares now this is a weakness
here on c4 and at the right moment you
want to advance your pawns that's clear
me and I believe that in fact in the
next move Bishop f4 is is not so precise
it was also criticized by Roni and this
is what pointed me to the smooth
I'm aronia and said that this Bishop f2
should be about equal yeah that's a very
fair assessment probably because this is
an important square that this Bishop now
watches over after Bishop f4 the problem
is that after c5 yeah blank immediately
can transform this position into
something that is quite comfortable
frame b5 and now 96 yeah this is just as
a weakness on b5 and yeah white hasn't
gained anything by putting the bishop on
on f4 and he now exchanged and played
Ruby want to cover the pawn
yeah black is slightly more comfortable
here but a very important part of this
of evaluating this position is that
Coyoacan was very much down on time we
see that right here it's about 40
minutes that he was behind but the next
couple of moves really cost lots of time
b6 e 5 not an easy decision
it took took a while to play that as of
course pawns yeah you cannot take those
moves back the pawns just don't go
backwards I don't like you 5 at all but
I
understand that he wanted to also make
sure that he for as a possible square
for the Queen computer sort of yeah it
gives black a slight advantage in any
case but I personally don't like them
move much but maybe it is okay we are
entering now and the following following
a face is some very interesting black
cam entered here now introducing a
simple idea white needs to react to that
and the reaction is cannot be a simple
thing like capturing look at this
yeah look at this this is hanging this
is a position where for example if I if
I if was just is not helping right at
all you simply don't have a move here
like that that you don't want to play
and this endgame is it's just not yeah
it's just terrible to play maybe it's
not lost outright but very uncomfortable
yeah the plate Queen to you for this was
the idea behind if I've anyway look a
form could move introducing this kind of
ideas and simply increasing the pressure
white is getting low on time yeah played
look see one that's an that's a funny
funny move age six yeah the idea of
rooks you wanna I need to show it if
black places the scary place c4 we see
this idea in the in the game but our own
ian makes a good move h6 and this is a
very little move that does not seem like
much but it's a very important tool that
I wanted to mention if you're in a
position where you have much more time
than your opponent and you have some
pressure but it's not like you see a
direct win direct combination win of
material or anything
just don't really see anything concrete
then it's very often a good idea to just
relatively quickly
not like blitzing but relatively quickly
play MOOCs that improves your position
somewhat and just gives him just gives
him the opportunity to have to do
something harmful to his position if you
have no time on the clock it's very
often easier to defend against concrete
threats than to to just play a move in a
position where you have many
possibilities yeah okay and this is this
kind of move is age six yeah white now
needs to move and what are you going to
do if six is a little bit of an
improvement move it give some space for
the King for the back rank it might
actually threaten g5 hmm could be a
threat hmm what should why - it turns
out that the computer recommends here
the move just bishop g3 but this is the
only move that actually keeps it turned
about about equal black is easier to
play but this is them the machines
recommendation which looks a bit strange
to be honest but it leaves this hanging
but okay black cannot cannot take off
this slip um yeah what kayaking did is a
very human reaction with the time we
played you played the h4 simply blocking
g5 the g5 idea but this is also a bit of
a weakness the ID weakens the whole the
whole kingside and you know very often
play those kind of small improvement
moves and in time travel of the opponent
often more effective than doing
something sharp
okay now night b2 was played c4 and
Queen to d7 yeah this is the idea now d3
yeah rupee one was played kayaking was
going coming
I was coming lower lower and lower on
the clock and I found an interesting way
to to defend now rook a to and now
Bishop to e3 yeah this this might might
be a mistake but we now come to to to to
the point well after this there is a
very very long basically forced sequence
of moves and the resulting position I
must be honest with you the resulting
position I cannot evaluate I really I
mean I on my own
couldn't evaluate it anyway but even
with the help of the computer I cannot
really tell if the resulting position
yeah how to assess it I really cannot
tell I mean I will give you lines and
some ideas but I'm not 100% sure but the
question if this is a mistake or not
hinges a bit on this it depends from the
evaluation of the upcoming position like
in 10 moves because this is almost
forced the computer wants to go here and
defend passively you're covering
covering before and yeah it's not it's
nothing too great yeah something like
that is the computers suggestion giving
black slight advantage at what Bishop e3
and kayaking now went after Knight a for
this is the critical means the fork
taiyaki know when true p3 this he had
planned beforehand when he played rupee
1 and Bishop e3 yeah and this is
interesting now he threatens rook t3
suddenly activating the rook and maybe
carrying even to d8 so this now forces
blacks reply black takes on d2 he has no
choice here gaining two minor pieces for
the rook which at first looks excellent
but there is some counter plane
ruk t3 check the check here you must
give the check to gain this temple king
h2 and now Knight B - all this is pretty
much forced no white plays rook t8 and
this was the whole idea of this maneuver
you activate the rook and set up the
spin oops
set up the spin on the bishop and
there's the additional idea of Queen
eight and just that after Queen c4 is
happening and this is what aronia also
had calculated and I mean it's a very
comfortable thing from from blacks point
of us that chant after this this was
played you cannot always check give
those gift-giver petrol this is a very
nice thing for black you can give this
to bad shot if you want or you can give
it at a later stage aronia didn't even
bother with repeating the position it
took only five
yeah g3 played this is also the best
move and now this position move 42 this
arises almost by force from this
position where I said that I cannot
really tell if this is a big mistake or
not because look at this this is
completely forced after Knight a for
Ruby 3 now black mistake otherwise rook
t 3 is even better for white and all
this it's completely check check many
moves but it's it's completely natural
flow and this is a funny position at
first if you if you give this to a
computer it says that black is just
clearly better but if you continue and
look at some lines you see that it is
not so clear-cut it is not so clear-cut
at all even if the computer initially
gives black like like a porn plus it's
not easy at all to do first of all sorry
there are simple things don't cut it if
if you go something like that for
example to cover on innovate white is
just doing that and two draws the game
very easily young this is not not on let
must do something
Activia now giving in check this is what
our own Ian did very national forgave
the check here so here this is the first
very interesting position which it's a
bit strange because at first you you
might think okay why is this interesting
King edge three what else yeah you don't
go back with your King this doesn't make
more sense but in fact it might be that
King aged one is a very good poof yeah
he played King edge three yeah
after only no thought but to be honest
after King edge one together with the
computer I couldn't find a win for black
maybe that's my problem
I mean that I'm simply not seeing it or
I cannot really yeah I don't find a win
the computer also goes goes down after
some time with his evaluation and at the
end it seems to be a drum that's really
funny what should like try 93 okay just
like in the game by by example I buy a
in the game after King Ashley there was
also 93 played so we know we must
examine that but the difference is check
and is this move in the game the Queen
d5 was not really possible at all
because Knight F to check if you now
play nice a to check I just go to g1 and
while this is looking threatening there
is no checkmate check this is not
leading to a mate at the same time White
has this very very direct threat
threatening mate in two moves and black
must do something against it okay you
can always go for a perpetual but how do
you actually win 90 f 2 is not do
anything you can give cheese here yeah I
love that one not that one 91 but here
you can give the ton of checks but how
do you actually win the game you just
stay on the second and first rank and
simply don't don't go upwards to h3 I
think it's just so wrong it's really a
more remarkable now after this chain
edge one and I tried other things I
tried other things let's say King h7
yeah just giving away this and now some
other moves than 93 93 would transpose I
tried 91 for example but here the
absolutely remarkable thing is and maybe
here is the whole problem of this line
that what can actually play Queen g4
check at first you might think okay this
is so this is nonsense isn't this just
just great for black you've got three
pawns yeah for the exchange but it's not
100% clear let's say Knight c3 rook
takes Knight b5 looks excellent three
passes but look at the upon what are you
doing against the upon now now here I'm
starting to pick up pawns go here okay
me six and what now white is very
serious counter play you can try that
but this is going to be it wrong I'm I'm
really a bit bit puzzled and yeah maybe
someone misses be able to find a win
after that but I don't
find it they both didn't mention any of
it in the press conference and yeah I
don't know I think it's wrong what else
can black try this this may be okay
check King out of it and something
something here maybe and this I didn't
analyze I'm just I'm just having this
idea right now maybe maybe that one
maybe Kim maybe this check is actually
not good
I could take here something like that
hmm interesting
yeah it's it's tough it's very tough to
analyze very very complicated stuff but
I think it was probably yeah better and
maybe drawing to go to h1 I'm not I
cannot wouldn't bet my life on it but it
seems tougher
he went to h3 with the King the much
more natural looking of course but still
93 now plate check and rook takes a fait
yeah okay this is pretty much clear and
only now only now in this position I
think kayaking is playing the the
absolutely decides of a mistake it's
playing rupee eight this this loses this
is no no I'm sure about something what
change this loses what is interesting is
that both players had calculated the
following line not this but the check
check and queer check this is very
natural of course and now
Queeny six and they both agreed that
this shorter should lose for white
you know takes and now they looked at
this line rook c8 normal move completely
normal looking
see for loops is 795 and now this
endgame yeah and this end came after the
check check King gauge 726 check check
and now where exactly do you want to
give us a check no sorry this check and
anywhere and here and this is probably a
relatively straightforward win as this
queen is nicely protecting against
checks and next you will push the C pawn
this is a line that both players had
seen and that's really easy line it's
long but I mean I had seen this as well
when I was watching and not difficult
but here after this they they only
looked at rook c8 and this is also what
I looked at exclusively I didn't have
any other idea and it turns out that
this is not so easy this position it's
not that lost
I believe the computer just wants to
play Queen King to g2 yeah I don't know
I know I'm not even sure what this move
is doing probably intending to walk the
King over to the Queen side and at first
you think okay what's the point of this
not just pushing the C pawn yeah you can
push the C pawn but then we need to play
this smooth and now c3 is not working I
just take the knight and black isn't
ending
why does intend to play rook to e4 and
I'm not I cannot really tell if this is
winning for black you can try of course
here let's say something like that you
can try there was some some nice tricks
get this but it's this really winning
yeah what now is going behind the pawns
of course white is never going to win
the game or anything but this is still
tough I'm not sure if it's if it's if
it's a flat-out win computer is only
giving black 0.4 or something it's not
like I'm arguing against the engines
evaluation usually here the computer is
basically saying it's a row which have
some difficulty to believe three pawns
it's quite a lot for the exchange
but maybe it's it's it's not not not
easy at all there are other way other
variations of this endgame by the way if
we look at this instead of instead of I
was playing this too quickly
instead of see for me this is also a
possibility you look at look at this
for example the black goes here to keep
this important structure protected this
is also a possibility and now black goes
here and maybe pushes this if you if you
are able to exchange on the kingside and
walk over with your king you maybe win
this but I'm not sure that you can
manage yeah let's say here rook rook c8
and yeah let's say here here how are you
how are you going to make progress now
if you move the King over yeah okay I
will go here I'm not 100% sure that it
is lost
it looks highly critical but it still
needs to be needs to be played in the
game he played through p8 and
is for sure losing just from from just
technically losing King must must go up
no no choice if you go back this check
94 deadly yeah go here and now you can
take the pawn and this is very important
you get rid of this important pawn no
check here no check on c6 like g-form at
Iranian plate Queen to c4
this was still very important it took 15
minutes to do that and Quincy 4 is
absolutely the only moves that is
winning in this position as this is the
fun thing with computer checks it really
tells you Quincy for only move winning
anything else it's still in a way tricky
or just not enough I was thinking
actually
why not c4 isn't this winning as well
I'm pushing the pawn I give my queen
some room yeah what can play a 4th and
now you must play accurately not to lose
it's really it's really that tough rook
AJ check and f5 check it threatened you
only have one way to draw a g5 and then
this check check here oh no this is the
wrong line even what is the drawing line
I forgot actually what the drawing line
is Quincy 5 hmm what was the drawing
line here there's only one way to draw
which I forgot maybe Quincy 5 but the
point is that's not really that
important as Quincy four is winning and
he played it after some thought one key
ideas of course here go to f4 and cover
important squares
Quincy eight and now Queen f4 and this
is so important covering here and
threatening Queen edge to checkmate yeah
and here white really has no choice as
this maid threat check forces him to
allow the Queen trade but now the C
point is just far too strong and a
couple of more moves and here kaya can
reside so very important game very
important it means that on the one hand
the kayaking is not out of it with - -
this is really impossible - um - yeah -
still fight from - - you would need to
basically we know all the rest of his
games almost so no no chance he's simply
not in good shape and our only end with
a very very important when after this
shaky performance that he had against
and Dracon and really a good game I'm a
really good game bye-bye Aronian cannot
really pinpoint any mistakes or whatever
I'm not too satisfied with my own
analysis effort here because I really
cannot tell what was happening if the
zone if all this is a draw after King
edge one worse than what was black's
mistake then I mean black was around
here yeah black was obviously pushing
yeah then is there some mistake like
here I mean technically speaking a
mistake it's not humans are not enough
machines and play perfectly though I'm
not trying to say that aronia played
badly or anything I just would like to
know if there was something that he
could have done to improve upon all that
if this is just a draw house tree even
even if this sounds very strange check
then there must have been some some way
to improve and I'm absolutely not sure
not sure where okay but maybe maybe I'm
also mistaken and this isn't a draw this
this strange King King h1 idea yeah
tough game a very very tough game
alright I hope you enjoyed the analysis
and maybe you can shed some light
upon upon those complications all right
thanks for watching and I'll be back
tomorrow with the all-important game
Aronian with white against Anand